do not take the contents of this video
as an endorsement of the bbc in its
current state the news arm of the bbc
continues to defend its recent history
of anti-trans articles ignoring the
damage to the trans community it is
facilitating in a pinned comment below
you'll find links to my original video
on the issue two follow-up videos from
the youtuber sean and a recent protest
speech from laura kate dale
thank you now on with the video
uh
well
this was always gonna happen eventually
[Music]
yeah i've been putting it off for long
enough it's time for me to start redoing
some of my doctor who rankings which
i've been putting off for
literally years now i have not done a
doctor who ranking video since the start
of jody whitaker's tenure as the doctor
and as it is now drawn to a close and i
do not expect the last few specials to
move the needle in terms of my overall
assessment of the various aspects of
that era
i think it's time for me to start
revisiting these now arbitrarily i'm
starting with ranking the series i think
probably just because we just wrapped
one up so hey why not and yes i will
over the course of this year no promise
on exactly when but over the course of
this year i do plan to redo my rankings
of companions the master and the doctor
so you can look forward to those down
the line but this was where i wanted to
start now as you may have guessed as
i've alluded i have done this before you
can check the previous ranking if you
want i haven't so
i don't actually know how much things
have changed i suspect more than a
little bit this isn't going to be a case
of me simply slotting in the three
uh series from jody whitaker's era into
the pre-existing list and not moving
anything else my assessment and opinions
on things change over time i don't
really care if it's inconsistent with
what i said before this is what it is
now now the other last thing to note
before we get started
there are going to be 14 entries on this
because while we have had properly 13
series series 1 through 12 and then flux
i am also counting the david tennant
specials so that is the next doctor
through the end of time part two as
their own thing that i'm going to be
ranking i don't really count the
specials in any other case than this
because well partially because i don't
know what series to lump them in with
part of the time well i do but it's
inconsistent what i mean by that is uh
the christmas invasion really feels like
it's a prequel to series two so i wanna
lump it in with that but then you have
things like twice upon a time at the end
of series 10 which is a coded to that so
it lumps into the one that came before
as opposed to the one coming after it's
super inconsistent i generally don't
deal with the specials except for the
david tennant specials the run i just
described that really kind of is its own
thing that is for all intents and
purposes at least as i am as far as i'm
concerned a series unto itself so that's
what we're ranking let's get started
with something that is probably going to
go down badly with a lot of folks right
off the bat
[Music]
number
14
flux
yeah i know i know look i i actually
agonized over this a bit because while i
did not like flux i also don't want to
feel like i am slamming it unnecessarily
i can be prisoner of the moment either
taking something that is fresh in my
mind and thinking of it more highly than
i might with time having passed or
thinking on it more harshly than i might
later on down the line
and so i really really kind of agonized
over this and i'll grant the distance
between this and the next one on the
list is not that great it's closer than
people might be thinking
but ultimately i did have to put this
one at the bottom because and i think
this is something that folks can agree
with me on
since it is a serialized story and while
there are many plot threads it is
ultimately telling one story over at six
episodes if that one story
doesn't work for you
that sinks the entire thing
so if you liked the one narrative being
told over these six episodes you are
going to write this a heck of a lot
higher than i am but if you're like me
and you didn't like it it drags the
entire thing down unlike every other
series where the occasional bad story or
just episode that didn't click with me
is balanced out by other stuff that did
every single part of this feeds into the
same story that i don't like and didn't
work for me so because of that i can't
put it any higher because it's telling
one story and it's one story that i
didn't like if you liked it you'd rank
it much higher get it totally this i i
am freely admitting that whether or not
you like that core central story that is
super subjective
you liking it not liking it you're not
wrong either way but at least grant me
that your liking of that single
continuous story is basically what
determines the entire thing when it
comes to placing this if you can agree
with me on that then i think we can move
on
number 13
series seven
series seven has always been kind of a
rough one and even when i went back and
revisited it it still is there's a
couple of episodes that i like and there
are honestly some that i seem to like a
heck of a lot more than other people i
like asylum of the daleks so sue me
but when looking at it as a whole as
opposed to just comparing what episodes
are good wet episodes are bad i mean i
do that as well that is a factor in this
but when i'm trying to take it as a
whole like what is the experience of
re-watching this series
the mid-season break does not do this
thing any favors at all i mean it wraps
up amy and roy's story decently enough
but it means that clara's entire
introduction is
completely negatively impacted by this
and i know some people love clara and i
have come to think better on clara
overall than i used to
but this first series she's not a
character
she's a macguffin she's a walking plot
device and she is
not well characterized at all the two
versions of her we got prior to this the
ones that effectively don't count are
better characterized than she is over
the entire half of the second half of
this thing but even if i am going to cop
to the fact that the first half of
series seven is better than the second
half of series seven i still have to
look at them as a continuous piece and
your second half's weaker than your
first and the transition between the two
is rough and clunky so
and yes i know some people will probably
defend it as well you need to treat it
like two different things since it is
two different stories look it's lumped
as series seven you buy it as a box set
it's sold as a single series that's how
i'm judging it deal with it
number 12.
series 11 jody whitaker's debut series
now
i was tempted to put off doing this list
for a little longer because i am
planning to start revisiting series 11
and 12 in the not so distant future so
it's possible my assessment on this
might change but i still feel
comfortable putting this about here
because there's certainly things about
well there's a couple of episodes that i
genuinely like quite a bit uh there's a
couple of episodes that i have issues
with but still think we're well executed
but there are also a couple of big
decisions made about series 11 that i
think were good choices or at least
interesting choices
even if they didn't pan out the way i
would have liked so to compare it with 8
series 7 which we just talked about
i look at the basics of what series
seven is which is two half stories
unconnected and introducing a whole new
character is gonna drive a whole bunch
of the plot and not have time to
properly characterize them and already
before i even watch it i'm going ah i
don't think this is going to be good
i look on paper what series 11 is doing
which is a bunch of self-contained
stories not relying a ton on uh
reintroducing old stuff and giving us
time with these adventures to have them
be their own thing wrapped up there
isn't really an overarching narrative
yes the villain at the very end is the
same one as the villain in the beginning
but they're not doing the mystery box
thing across it which is something i've
been very very sick of and on paper i'm
in favor of all these it still didn't
quite come together
as i would have liked but it's still got
some standout episodes in my opinion the
highlight in particular being it takes
you away which i will still defend i
know lots of people don't like it i like
it
quite a bit
and overall even the episodes that i
don't like there's really only one that
actively ticks me off that's our acting
is in the uk for the record and the rest
they don't
annoy me that much so the ideas being
interesting enough the sort of fun of
having a new doctor and the episodes
that i do think are better do bring this
up just above series seven before we
move any further this is where i'm going
to pause and say that's basically the
series where i'm like these aren't
especially good and
i'm not particularly looking forward to
revisiting anytime soon so as we move on
from here we are into series that yes
i'm going to be issuing criticisms of to
justify a lower placement on the list
but i do like
so
the three we just did those are really
the only ones that i would say they're
they're kind of bad and from here on i'm
gonna be like look they're good but
okay so little perspective shift as we
move on to
number
eleven series two
i think tenant nostalgia clogs a lot of
people's brains on this series two is
rough it's not all bad and there's some
great stuff in it i still love the
impossible planet in the saint pitt
two-parter there's some other episodes
that i really really enjoy in this and
even ones that i don't think are that
great self moments i love things like
tooth and claw give me things like that
the finale is terrifically emotionally
focused
but when this one's bad
it's real bad and i know most people are
gonna cite
love and monsters on that but loving
monsters is not even the worst offender
to me fear her is a worse story in terms
of execution and the idiot's lantern i
will always i have a hard time thinking
any any episode of doctor who will ever
take its place as i think the worst
thing the revive series has ever done
because it is
freaking harmful in addition to just
being bad i've ranted about this before
if you need that i don't want to go off
on it again
but
yeah
this thing is a case of there's
definitely good stuff great stuff even
in this but the stuff that's bad is
really dragging it down
number 10
the david tennant specials
now almost kind of inverse to series two
unlike that one where it was a case of
there's great stuff but other stuff
dragging it down this is a case where
most of it kind of lands middling for me
the stuff that is weaker like the planet
of the dead and
aspects of the next doctor isn't
terrible and i'm still okay to watch it
it's not something that i deliberately
skip during a re-watch or would be
tempted to
but at the same time the stuff that is
better and is good
like the end of time parts one and two i
enjoy but i don't think is great and i
know everybody loves waters of mars more
than i do and it's good i appreciate it
but i don't love it and that's basically
it that's the reason for the placement
of the specials here there's no story in
this that i'd love
pretty much every other series has at
least one story that i love even series
11 gave me that but this one
yeah
the only reason it's higher than series
2 is there isn't really anything i hate
either so
yeah there we go
number nine
series 12. yes this is going to be the
highest ranked of the jody whitaker
series on this particular list and i
thought series 12 was stronger than
series 11
pretty much across the board uh the
characters for the most part felt like
they were working better although in
many cases still not as well as i would
have liked but we got an introduction to
this new master i like sasha dewan in
the part a lot it gave me another at
least one episode that i deeply adore
which is can you hear me it had some
other really strong entries like the
hunting of villa dia daddy even it's
more disposable stories like the nikola
tesla one are still fun and enjoyable
and i would have been happy to put this
higher except except
except finale
timeless children
man do i hate that
not only do i think it's a bad idea but
it's delivered so
narratively poorly they basically pull
the doctor out of the story going on
dump a ton of exposition on her that
does not actually impact the immediate
proceedings going on remove her from the
exposition machine quickly wrap up the
plot and then that's it it's
not just an idea i can't stand it is
such a terrible way to deliver it this
is right up there with the architect at
the end of the matrix reloaded like i'm
not sure there are too many worse ways
you could have thought of to convey
these ideas and yeah that alone pulls it
down
quite a few spaces from where this
series might otherwise have landed i try
not to hold the single worst episode in
a series against it but when it's the
finale and when it was the thing
everything was building to yeah it's
it's gonna drag it down
number
eight fittingly enough is series eight
the first series of peter capaldi's run
as the doctor
i
have more appreciation of this now but a
lot of that comes in hindsight because
a lot of what i like about this at this
point has to do with how much i have
come to love and deeply adore
the arc of capaldi's 12th doctor again
i'll reference you a video for like why
it matters so much to me the journey
that he goes through over series eight
nine and ten
and knowing where he's gonna end up
makes me much more appreciative of where
he started it's kind of like how yeah in
a new hope luke skywalker is kind of
whiny but i was going into toshi station
to pick up some power converters but if
he didn't start that way him ending up
where he does by the end of return of
the jedi wouldn't have the weight i am a
jedi like my father before me
so
when you can end a character's journey
well
then yeah it's okay if they if they
didn't quite click for you at first and
he didn't quite click for me at first
despite that there are still some very
good episodes in here there's mummy on
the orient express which is terrific we
get the introduction of missy who i love
and i'll say this flat out and i will
stand by it
clara has way better performance
chemistry with capaldi than she did with
smith it wasn't
the worst
with uh the 11th doctor but she clicks
with capaldi's doctor so much better
and it makes me like clara more so yeah
series eight it's a decent one all
around
number seven
series three
i think people um feel i'm a bit harsh
on this one but look even on revisits
and accepting that there are definitely
things that are good here and some
individual episodes and stories that are
phenomenal i mean blink utopia human
nature and the family of blood amazing
stuff
and i also love martha
but i kind of love martha in spite
of this series than because of it
because i feel like
granted it's part of the narrative that
the doctor doesn't fully appreciate her
properly but i can't help but feel like
the show itself doesn't really have a
full appreciation of what it had with
martha as is partly evidenced by how
quickly she fell for him i mean i don't
like that plotline in the first place
but how quickly they saddled her with
that ah
not a big fan at all it also doesn't
help that while i have softened on john
sims master because the three times we
see him are wildly different this is the
iteration i like the least between this
and end of time and then uh series 12.
so that doesn't help either but still
good stuff still some strong stuff like
i said i do like these
number six
series six
this is one that lost steam as it went
along unfortunately because a lot of the
two-parters and even the start of an
overarching story are really solid here
i
love the concept of the silence i think
it's one of the coolest creepiest things
that modern doctor who has given us i
know most people would give that to the
weeping angels i actually find the
silence creepier personally at least in
their introduction when first brought in
here but we've got other amazing
two-parters as well with things like the
rebel flesh and the almost people and
then there's stories like the girl who
waited so much good stuff in this
the finale's a mess
but unlike say series 12 the finale
doesn't tick me off it just frustrates
me because it's got even some neat ideas
but it is a jumbled mess that doesn't
know what to do with all the things it's
juggling and it feels like a very limp
payoff to huge swaths of not only this
series story but river songs story
overall so
that is largely what is bringing this
one down as i said not dragging things
down quite as badly as the timeless
child did for series 12 but
it does hold it back a bit finishing
weekly is never gonna work in a series
favor
number five
series nine
yeah
believe it or not
as much as i hate hellbent
it's not dragging this series down as
much as it might have otherwise because
yeah i do hate hellbent
i i really do i freely admit that i
don't get it i don't i i must not get it
i don't understand what it's doing
because if it's doing what i think it's
doing none of that is stuff that it
should be doing none of that makes any
sense is a thing that you would want to
do so i must not get it but i've
revisited the thing multiple times
people have explained to me why they
like it and i'm not negating any of
those arguments i still really hate it
so i just got to pretend that this ends
at heaven sent move on now am i being
gentler on a really bad final episode in
a series because it's my favorite doctor
yeah possibly
i i have to acknowledge that's that's uh
certainly an option but i really do
think that pretty much all the rest of
this is really strong or at least was
interesting if didn't quite nail it the
two-parter with the shielder it could
have been more than it was but even that
one i don't think it's bad but then
we've got these other stories that are
just really good strong stuff there are
specific hiccups along the way with
things like the magician's apprentice
and the witch's familiar but it's so
much fun
watching these characters watching
capaldi watching missy and having the
chemistry between them watching them
interact and then we've got really well
thought out two parters like under the
lake and before the flood and face the
raven is really good and heaven
sent i think that's the big difference
between
this and say series 6 or series 12
where the finales were dragging them
down a bit
because here
there is an episode
that is
as good as hell bent is bad it is being
counterbalanced by something of quality
actually higher than the issues i have
with hellbent and that yeah
that helps balance the books
number four
series one
my appreciation of series one has gone
up quite a bit over the years i've been
harsher on it in the past largely
because of aspects that the show's moved
on from since then there's a lot of the
more camp aspects of doctor who which
again were legit to try out classic
doctor who could be pretty camp at times
but never went down right for me things
like the trash can devouring mickey or
the slovene and there's a couple of
floundering episodes like the long game
and i think
father's day is possibly one of the most
overrated episodes in the entire history
of modern era doctor who but
christopher eccleston
is
so good
in this
he
carries this so much and again am i
biasing it in his favor because i don't
have another series from him to be able
to award above this one possibly
but he really is that good
i fell in love with his doctor
immediately
within seconds of him being on screen
nice to meet you rose run for your life
that does not always happen my favorite
doctor is capaldi i didn't love him for
over a full series
but eccleston
captures this sense of fun and adventure
covering a layer of very deep very
recent hurt
and he brings that across
so
masterfully and also i'll be honest i
like the dynamic between rose and the
doctor better here than i did with
tennant so there's that as well but
again this is also a case of the
episodes that are good are some of the
best in the entire
series
the two-parter of the empty childs and
the doctor dances
[Music]
it goes back and forth with a couple of
others as possibly being my single
favorite of the entirety of modern era
doctor who it's
that good and
a lot of the rest of the series is also
incredibly good i still am probably a
bit harsher on it than some people but i
have to acknowledge
if i can't praise eccleston anywhere
else then this deserves a slot right
where i put it
number three
series five
this was the first of matt smith's
series and i would say also by a
considerable margin his strongest
now still some things that i'm iffy on
the uh cracks in time
is not a overarching story that i
particularly love it's fine it works
well enough
i actually don't like the big bang as a
finale but it functions i don't dislike
it because what it's doing makes no
sense to me or i think it's
it's damaging or it couldn't possibly
have ever worked i just
am bored by it it feels like an exercise
in narrative not tying than anything
else but
all that said
matt smith nailed this character
immediately i got him as the doctor
right off
he came fully formed there are some
doctors and this isn't a complaint about
some doctors oftentimes watching them
find themselves and become who they're
going to be
over the course of a story again capaldi
he's my favorite that can be incredibly
rewarding but there is something
about a version of the doctor who shows
up and within seconds into a new
regeneration
is fully formed and this is who you're
gonna be on this journey with for the
remainder of his tenure
and that's what you get with matt smith
right out of the gate
this is who we got
and i love him i love him a lot and
while i may not feel the finale is as
strong as other people think the first
part of that finale the pandorica opens
that's a great setup great tension love
it the angel two-parter works really
solid the opening episode the 11th hour
is probably the strongest start of a
modern era of doctor who period we've
got amy's choice and we've got vincent
and the doctor which is just
beautiful this is a really good piece of
work now we're about to get to the top
two and i gotta tell you the
the difference between these is a hare's
breadth it's so close
but let's start with
number two
series four tenants best both in terms
of his performance
the overall quality of the stories that
he's in
and
paired with his best companion
donna noble i do like tenet despite
popular belief i don't like him nearly
as much as a lot of the fandom does but
i do like him
but i love donna
donna
steals my heart and then breaks it by
the end every time she is everything i
want in a companion she is not
romantically entangled with him she is
his best friend she will push back on
him for being an idiot she's here to
have fun and they do like so often it
feels like lately there is the supposed
pitch that the doctor and the companions
are doing these things to have fun but
you frequently lose the sense that they
actually are having fun whenever they're
on any of these adventures it's like
assumed that the fun happens in between
the episodes we see these two have fun
while they are together
yes things get dire at points including
some episodes that i think are deeply
under-appreciated like fires of pompeii
but these two
know how to have fun around and with
each other and this has got
a bit of an indulgent finale but i think
a really strong one and as i said a bit
of a heartbreaking one as well it's also
got another one of my favorite two
parters with silence in the library and
the forest of the dead and it's also a
fantastic introduction to river song
whatever you think about what happened
with her later her intro is
stellar and there are some weak moments
in this i don't like the doctor's
daughter very much at all and the
sontaran two-parter is basically just
fine
but there's also turn left which is an
episode i have come to appreciate a lot
more in the years since it first aired
and
midnight
holy crap
between having some stellar episodes and
consistently one of my favorite doctor
companion pairings
this one's hard to top
but there is one i'm going to place over
it
number one
series 10.
this is my favorite doctor
my favorite performance from him
during the series this is where the
doctor's journey
landed
right where i needed him to be
the journey he goes on in terms of the
characterization from series eight to
series nine to here
for me is a journey of finding
the exact
sweet spot for the character and for me
it does feel like a journey and it
doesn't feel like well they were
inconsistent and they didn't nail the
character until the last one no it feels
like he went on a journey and it's a
journey that makes sense to me and it
lands him
right where i want him
the companions are fantastic
bill is great nardole is perfectly
utilized after being annoying in the
stories where he was initially
introduced during some specials here
he's really well used there are
phenomenal individual episodes in this
that starts really strong with the pilot
thin ice is severely underappreciated
oxygen is terrific
extremist is really smartly dumb we get
missy back who and like missy and
cavaldi i will never tire of but as much
as there is a lot of good
in this series already
the finale
and the final episode specifically
world enough in time
is one of the best dark episodes of
doctor who
and
the doctor falls
to me
serves as the summation
and
the essence
of everything i love
about
not only peter capaldi's doctrine
specific but the doctor in general
him
saying why he does what he does to the
master and to missy
is what i will always hold up
as the purest essence of what the doctor
is
i do what i do because it's right
because it's decent
and above all it's
kind and for that to cap off this series
a series that i already loved
i have to put it at number one
it's my favorite doctor
in the best stories that he got
at the
peak of his characterization having
truly
earned becoming who he is
and then his fear at losing that
but being willing to sacrifice it
regardless
because
it's kind
it's just that
just kind
that to me is the best of doctor who
and that's why for me
series 10
gets the number one spot
what's your ranking how badly do you
disagree with mine whatever your
thoughts are stop signing down in the
comments let's talk about it
it's patreon you want to support what i
do and keep this entire operation up or
running this is my living at this point
so any assistance is greatly appreciated
there's also a link there in the
description plus links to twitch channel
instagram twitter my po box address etc
etc etc it's all down there check it out
but don't worry too much about it
because at the end of the day my friends
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
thanks for sticking around into the
credits none of this would have been
possible without my patreon supporters
in particular i want to thank robin
powell tracy scrabbit vincent paul
partalucci robin moore jayla gourle and
bookworm
thanks for keeping this going and to
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]